what you do have to be to be a good
judge in a jury trial is a good
manager a good person manager you need
to be able to manage a courtroom
with people
defendants
Witnesses jurors
barristers
public gallery
staff you have to know what's going on
in every quarter of your courtroom that
comes through so strongly in your book
as I was reading it I can see how
carefully you think about the managing
different people and what this person is
about to say and why they're saying it
it's fascinating yeah and I mean if you
can't do
where we're dealing with really serious
stuff trial after trial is going to go
wrong
now there are ways
of managing most circumstances
you know I've had cases where I
certainly had one case where um
the victim was a young girl who was
wholly innocent
completely and utterly innocent it was a
case of mistaken identity when she was
stabbed to death and
the public Gallery was packed with
um not just her family but with her
school friends with local people and
they
all arrived on the first day wearing
t-shirts
emblazoned with her face and her name
and one entirely understands how they
felt
but they were sitting right opposite the
jury
and when the defendants
barristers said how can they have a fair
trial when the jury is staring into the
image of this dead girl
emblazoned upon t-shirts worn by
young school friends of hers
at local people who knew and loved her
they had a point too and so one had to
find
a way of
balancing
the issues there one had to find a
solution and believe me there is no
textbook that gives you the answer to
that and um
you can only do it by
understanding what's going on and using
a bit of imagination and finding some
solution and what was the solution in
that particular case Wendy
um in that particular case I am said to
those and I mean this wouldn't
necessarily have worked but it did
um I said to those in the public gallery
that I entirely understood why they were
doing what they were doing as I entirely
understood they wanted to keep the image
of uh this girl close to their hearts
that they might reflect upon the nature
of the trial and the purpose of the
trial and the fact that she would be
closer to their hearts if they turned
their t-shirts inside out and they all
went off and turned their t-shirts
inside out
wow
foreign